it's no secret that most journalists
lean left or that they would find a
vulgar and far left dinner speaker so
funny but the White House Correspondents
Association extol Zitz commitment to the
First Amendment and an independent media
how independent though is the White
House press corps that is so
overwhelmingly leftist how can it be
independent and how committed to free
speech is a group that only invites
comedians to their marquee dinner who
attack the right let's examine this
hypocrisy with Jeffery Lord of the
American Spectator Lee Habib host of our
American stories and Ari Fleischer who
was george w bush's first press
secretary great to see all of you guys
tonight let's start with you Ari
did you go to the dinner you probably
didn't go you've Bend enough of those
things I don't know I haven't been to
one of those I haven't been since I was
at the White House I'm happy to report
so what was your reaction when you first
started seeing the clips rollin you know
frankly until I saw it on your show I
had no idea how vulgar it really was I
had seen a lot of the excerpts things
that was said about Kelly Ann things
that were said about Sarah Huckabee but
I did not know just how bad it was and
it was bad when I heard about it so you
know the real problem here is that the
press is killing themselves and they
just don't get it
they're an industry and decline and
they're in decline because half of
America the Republicans and conservative
half doesn't doesn't trust them and it
evens like this just make it worse and
the press still doesn't understand how
bad last night was when you hear Juan
Williams defend it when you were the
most reasonable liberals defend it and
as you pointed out Laura pan the crowd
see the laughter the press doesn't get
it uh Lea want to go to you you Italy
was my old executive producer and radio
and partner in crimes like 17 years ago
back to law school and Lea it was your
idea to play a lot of these sound bites
tonight so you know you said a lot of
people didn't see this they have to see
just how vulgar and low it was to
understand how far we've sunk with the
media and the so-called defense of the
First Amendment but the the
double standard here is glaring for
anyone who wants to see it about the
treatment of women the me2 movement you
know I am woman hear me roar all that
you know it's funny lore is for the last
few weeks we've heard the press
excoriate the lack of vetting by the
White House they didn't do a proper job
with a veteran's affair a gentleman who
is ultimately dismissed and yet they
couldn't vet this comedian don't they
have YouTube
don't they have Google can't they just
watch this woman's performance on The
Daily Show what's fascinating Laura and
what Juan missed is that 95% of these
jokes were aimed at Republicans she
didn't spread it around
she just targeted mostly women 6 to 7
minutes straight were vile repulsive
jokes aimed at and they weren't jokes
they were attacks aimed at women and
these weren't just jokes it was like a
public shaming and it was just
disgraceful and to listen to the
audience laugh and we wish only we wish
we could see who was laughing and at
what because these jokes were
disgraceful and the laughs continued and
they continued and the key here lore is
that there was a winner here there were
two winners one was the comedian because
my goodness she's gonna get a really big
deal with HBO she'll be following Bill
Maher in the next three months
she was playing to her audience a
liberal set of journalists and Trump by
the way was a winner to the smartest man
not in the room he was playing to his
audience America yeah Jeffery Lord you
wrote a piece today for The Spectator
about this and this was supposed to be
about the First Amendment and beating
back those who would want to intimidate
people from speaking out on any issue
yet there was something desperately
missing at the last hour of Saturday
night's dinner well that's that's right
Lord but first I have to tell you of
breaking news that the Federal Elections
Commission is starting to investigate
the White House Correspondents
Association for a multi-million dollar
contribution to the Trump campaign in
2020 you can see these clips that you
played you can see these clips that you
played all through the election season I
guarantee let's go through 2018 where's
Jeffrey we're gonna aim toward the right
good point good point but you're
absolutely right Laura and
and and this is the kind of thing and
you should know that I asked the
president of the White House
Correspondents Association several days
ahead of the dinner whether they would
specifically be defending conservatives
by name included you Sean Hannity Kevin
Williamson and I got no response total
complete silence this is the serious
thing here basically this boils down to
free speech for me but not for thee and
when push comes to shove they are not
therefore conservatives and that is a
real serious problem and you see it not
just in television and radio but you see
it on college campuses
good lord when ben shapiro needs serious
police protection and there's a riot
just to give a speech on a college
campus or ann coulter has to has to
cancel something because of a threat of
violence and where are these people
there there's not a peep to be heard
from them and it's disgraceful re i want
to go to you because you know whether
it's this comedian
you know ridiculing an abortion or
talking about knocking the baby out or
if the first daughter Ivanka Trump is it
described in the most disgusting manner
I think those are gifts to Americans who
might be kind of oh it's a midterm
election cycle I'm not gonna get out and
vote I think the Democrats tend to
always take it too far they they go too
far to the left and they end up
offending people who might not even be
all that political but they find this
gross they find it gross in this new
millennial poll looks like 16,000
registered voters 18 to 34 shows their
support for Democrats over Republicans
has slipped by about nine percentage
points over the past two years the 46
percent overall and they increasingly
say the Republican Party is a better
steward of the economy I think these
Democrats re ought to be really careful
about the supposed what moment we might
have here well I'm not talking continue
on this dinner and the connection to the
Democrats I think is not as direct it
was the press that did this it wasn't
the Democratic Party the Democratic
Party loves these dinners because they
like to laugh at these jokes but I think
the future
this dinner if it even has a future is
it should be Democrats only Laura
Republicans should just stop going
elected officials don't go staff don't
go
certainly president Trump won't go but
you know I remember when I did used to
go to the dinner and the humor actually
was pretty good back then and this was
some fifteen years ago it wasn't as
cutting as nasty but even then it had a
red carpet at Hollywood celebrities the
pre parties the post parties goodness
how much on earth did they pay this
comedian for this at a time when
newsrooms are going broken laying people
off how much did they lay out for all
the entertainment the lavishness this is
not what the press is supposed to be
about and it's why the press is
distancing themselves especially from
the blue-collar workers who elected
Donald Trump people the Democrats and
the press never saw their story prior to
2016 this is the presses greatest
problem they are so disconnected from
their readers and the viewers it's one
of the biggest reasons why I trust in
the media is dropping and people don't
want to read them in the same numbers
they used to leha babe
Laura ninety to ninety two percent of
the jokes were aimed at Republicans and
ninety two percent of the journalists
are Democrats and a lot of Americans are
starting to see journalists as an arm of
the Democrat Party and that's really the
problem they got to get out in the
country and meet the American people
more and respect them yeah Jeff Lord
last word last year I was at this dinner
and the president was here in Harrisburg
and I was getting text during the dinner
while everybody was mocking the
president and the dinner from a reporter
covering the rally here and talking to
people and she said he's more popular
now than he was when he was running for
election and of course he carried
Pennsylvania this kind of thing shows
the real divide here and it's pretty sad
but it's pretty definite no question and
Donald Trump said I'd rather be with the
real people than the Washington people
and I think he nailed a guy's fantastic
panel thanks so much